[Music]
series we are of Concordia okay is the
world that we're looking at that you
were on now I can't told you guys we're
all starting but we are going to be
starting the town of blue cliff so if
you guys want it pick if you want to
zoom over to it when you get a chance if
you're okay guys blue cliff right here
next to there Esther Esther breakers we
are going to be following the tale of
four adventurers glory seekers somebody
even say they've been brought to this
land with tales of treasure and danger
we have a very well mixed group if you
guys want to go around we'll start with
pika if you guys just wanna kind of give
a little bit of a there so you can see
myself how did I know that I like men
already what the [ __ ] I like girls okay
give me a brief summary of who you are
and what brought you here why what are
you trying to do what is wrong I am a
charismatic young boy and I'm on a quest
to be the greatest adventurer with my
ragtag group of friends and
you know I hope they sing songs part
missing tales of my great deeds when I
passed right okay beautiful melody
melody what has brought you into this
group and what are you trying to get out
of it melody oh this would be your time
come on what I'm trying to do is find a
balance between nature and mankind and
I'm just I'm here to make sure
relationships stay good and awesome all
right Craig what are you doing what is
your character like give me a race run
down in right away okay you know on my
whole pile just yeah give me like give
me like a few sentence excerpt of what
your what your goals are and I just my
name is Craig assalaam elite
my name is Craig Newsome rama Lear I'm a
paladin elf some class Dragonborn don't
tell Alex and my pants i freed a
zelda-like and and i got bored with
hanging out with the pretty princess and
now i'm looking for more adventure with
some friends there you go all right and
last but not least Shawn me a quick
rundown of what you're doing and how you
got here I really I want to read my
whole bio but I will someone's rates
well I grew up treat it no no it was a
point in life when Shana soldier could
ask for no more he grew up a very rich
son of a silk trader in town whose
family had much more money than everyone
else's as he grew he never knew that his
parents were not actually his true
parents but rather a stable family
village each night Sean would sleep but
the parents that had kidnapped him as a
baby and raised him as the silk trader
would suck the life force from him and
he didn't know it so his parents after
many many years created a plan to free
him and they broke in that collapsed the
building on the warlock parents but they
knew that that pile of rubble would only
hold them for so long
so they explained to their son Sean the
sorcerer who he was what his lineage was
that he came from a long line of magic
wielding sorcerers and they gave him a
list of a few spells and told him he had
to run far far away because he's
warlocks had never tasted a power as
strong as his before so they'll be out
to searching to the ends of the realm so
now he works every day to get his strong
spells and its dexterity and fighting
ability up so that he can face the evil
that pursues he's dropping into kind of
like the beginning of this fellowship
trademarked encanta Singh from the
beginning of their journey together okay
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna drag you
guys in cliff and you guys are going to
be yeah and what you guys are going to
be you guys are going to be at the local
tavern oh whoa what the [ __ ] you guys
should you guys should be pulled in Alex
bruised and just so you know back in
these days this is about the 1500s of
this time period on fact they didn't
drink water back then because there's no
way to really get it unless you're
drinking Mountain water like off the
river not really unclean water there's
no way that's purified so Mead was the
primary cuz I don't work over there I
left or is that just a green person so
you guys are Ford here yes these people
know who we are can only say what
characters we are exciting so melody is
the elf druid right here okay
you have crane yes the elf paladin if
Sean who is the elf warlock or
outsourcer sorry and Pikachu who is the
elf barbarian a full of squad L squad
you know all right so you we come down
in the middle of the four of you guys
conversing with the town sheriff hey
which would be right here
oh oh okay guys are trying to get your
feet wet you guys are trying to get your
feet wet and grow a name for yourself so
you guys have been kind of meandering
through small towns trying to find Oz
and then jobs how to be able to get some
sort of reputation and you figured well
you guys are going to stop here and
kindly ask around and you guys have
chosen where we have listened yes no you
will drop right into the conversation
like I would like to ask the sheriff
that's nothing
though he has any major disturbances
that are affecting the villages of
lately that he would kindly reward us
for solving for it any better
rub his chin and rub his chin this is a
small town for for yourself I think I
know that the farmer has had some issues
with his cattle recently it's nothing
too serious but if it's true it's what
you say you're just looking to kind of
get your feet wet then I do think it
might be a fair start we also have the
town Alchemist who had something stolen
from his warehouse if you are looking
for something a little easier those
might be something up your alley guys
what do we think Craig is let's say you
let's have one more glass of need before
we travel out okay good sounds great
bartender comes on over drops drops for
extra needs in front of you two robbers
victory to us all Alvin Bob burns the
with one gold here's a quick rundown
currency okay one gold is ten silver and
silver is a hundred copper to copper
okay so what you're gonna have to do is
ask him for change so we get nice so
he'll take your gold
he'll take who's giving him the money
I'll give Craig is Craig is good girl
pay the good man hey you're pretty funny
you know like give him a cool flick like
flip the coin Adam bring me my change he
kind of scoffs at you
gives you an I roll and walks back to
collect change for you and then I was
back with a pretty hefty sack and just
drops it right in front of you the table
and walks away yeah smaller what he
dropped in front of you was five silver
and 4846 copper wait how many copper
today he took 50 copper before me oh man
oh wait no you're right it was five soap
no it's five silver and then for each
it's I'm sorry
I'm not doing math right cuz he has five
silver I'm 50
oh wait no you're right what's up mark
ow how you doing what's up chat what's
up Jason what's a biscuit maker yeah so
he gives you he gives you 10 silver he
gives you 5 silver back and then 46
copper because 9996 copper 96 copper
that's what I cover here to the Cheers
thank you this Jan applying libation so
melody do you think the deal with that
wench is over there there's like eight
beds in this place do you think she's
married as bartender we may be going off
to die we got a buttload of gold in our
pocket
I'm thinking I'm thinking we're gonna
save our Lord with getting bobbi's done
gotcha
don't waste your essence hurry up I want
to do something store the following
I think if we do the farmer first his
Alchemist sounds a little bit more
complicated despite being entry-level I
think the nature will bless us on earth
on our quest with the alchemists if we
see farmers overthinking this
I think the farmer we're gonna fight a
creature that's been killing livestock
for food and the alchemist we're gonna
fight a dude who's been stealing stuff
from him so who do we want to fight
first a guy or a creature a guy a guy
let's go let's go let's go to the farm
okay guys so we're gonna drag you guys
outside
teleportation the you guys are out front
so you guys should have full control
over your character you should be able
to click and drag the car I never zoom
out it's really big okay
building stuff but you have okay guys we
gotta find this farm so so we get thirty
feet okay so we walk to the phone you
guys can drag yourself right over to the
farm in which you find very short stout
dwarf okay just hair coming off his
forearms and it's almost like an
overabundance coming out of the V of his
neck where's really raggy shirt is and
he's just he's almost fetal position
crying Craig yes is this your brother
sure
wrong with you why are you on your
ground crying that's he he notice you
guys walking up and he really quickly
tries to compose himself it's just like
you know dwarves are not known for
emotion but he's okay he gets up wipes
his legs he takes a very heavy sigh I
just don't know what to do
the I've been trying my hardest but last
night the last six of my cattle were
stolen and that's all I have to live off
of that's my trade you know that cutting
the slaughtering these calves and
selling the meats the various cities
that's that's where my that's my living
that's my livelihood now it's just gone
did you have sex with your cattle
forgive my friend good else we mean
nothing but the best of intentions we
hope to solve this problem for you what
is it worth to you to have your cattle
back he's just priceless but I would be
able to pay you what I could for the
return of these cattle these would be I
would be able to pay handsomely for
return of my cattle these are fake
negotiations mr. look we are still
nonetheless interested is there any
additional information you can give us
about when these cattle were taken in
which way they may have gone I know that
they were there in the pen tonight they
were in the pen last night and by the
time the rooster used it whatever
they've got I came out so just so you
guys know as you walk in you're not
gonna need to know any investigation at
the back of this fence is broken
do we notice any footprints leading away
from that broken fence
give me an investigation check that
would be in your character sheet bill
quick I just wanted to say I meant you
no disrespect sir how much your cattle
meant to you we are not you mean the
world to me all right
free bread you you're kind of just
strolling around kind of looking around
seeing what you can see you notice
multiple different footprints give me
also a history check free bread who does
anyone Sean he's history check history
check six different pairs of footprints
you can kind of tell cuz some are
wearing shoes one person has one foot
and the other one is just a shoe like
one of these things is true only one
foot and you recognize distinctly that
these are gobbling footsteps and
footprints oh you know that goblins
usually they kind of run with pack
tactics you're never usually running
into one you're usually gonna run into a
group of them so you did but it's like
you knew that already because you see
multiple different pairs of footprints
okay fellas what do we want to do here
is this guy offering us dis ambiguous
amount of money to go to our possible
deaths are we willing to help this guy
may we take you how much do these offer
wealthy reward you give us fine cereals
again slay the Beast that took your
friend kettle puree was bringing back my
pure breeds I'd be willing to give you
100 gold pieces
as an aside the body that guy is
definitely [ __ ] his cows 400 gold
charging other people too yeah yes I
think we should take this what do you
think we should we will end these in
these goblins and we will bring this
Dead or Alive
are you blind
I don't know anyway we will take your
mission 99 gold I go ahead if you won't
give me that
intimidation right you're just you're
just pushing a ship forward against yeah
we don't want to make him do everyone
right let me try persuasion can I now do
a persuasion check so you walk up and
you push him you do something like into
the back of a barn door and he's he kind
of like scurries back to like the back
of the fence because it's foreign one
and he is considering you see and he's
just like if you do something sheriff I
don't see charisma save it's not
Christmas safe it's under skills yeah
then you would give me a persuasion you
wouldn't give me a you wouldn't give me
a career thank you let me try my
persuasion
that's fine fifty-fifty son hold on let
me see I have my own dice for these
situations see I should be the pursue so
fun cuz yeah you beat his you you be the
same he seems to relax a little bit
well don't know persuasion wait I mean
say what you want say don't listen work
out for me and my friends when you no
harm
I apologize for the short blonde haired
Alvin the [ __ ] trying to mess with you
he is a little feisty well we we would
like to do is go save your cattle and
not have any more dispute we will take
the hundred gold and chase them down and
I apologize for any any further
inconvenience gold upon completion yes
sir
sounds good fellows I'll squad let's do
it
let's go ask one I just need to give me
you need to give me a nature check so
you can't see but it's about a hundred
feet of my grass plane and and then hit
mildly dense woods so the reason I had
you that's like if you don't if you
don't if you're not that good at
following tracks through there you'll
get lost and you kind of lose your way
your way but sean has the lead he's seen
goblin trucks before and he knows how to
follow him and he will
about let's say it's about three and a
half hours of travel through these woods
and trailing you guys to whoa the you
guys came in for about the Northwest so
you guys are over here you guys are up
in the you guys are up in the trees like
not in it but you guys are coming out of
the trees so you're not spotted you guys
are about let me give you as a distance
I take my very indecent cover in a sense
whoa hold on let's what honestly I'm
doing his shots up front so what you see
how do we know we see an enemy what
their HP is or anything you will not
know the HP I know the HP okay okay
you'll do damage to it if you know if
you do damage to it I'll drop the HP and
you'll see how much it chunks okay okay
all right guys now let's listen most of
your attacks are probably pretty close
so we want to truck these guys so that
we can have the element of surprise
I shall take front for I embark my I
have a token attack range
I have 10-foot attack range with poison
so so you go from core body once those
clicker spells and then it'll show your
attacks yours is basically it's a 5 foot
you're you you have to be ready for
someone to it to Bailey right what about
my well then your javelin is
your javelin is for me right says plus
work I do a high jump that's kind of
like a surprise it should be it should
be a javelin is thirty to sixty feet so
you have to be at least you can be six
feet away but it you're gonna if you
throw a 60-foot javelin it will be a
disadvantage because that's a hawk what
if I do this what if I do this Shani
what if I go over to this tree because
30 feets right right here so if I sneak
to this treaty hold on I gotta switch
back to my landline my pin so when I
switch to this tree stay behind it for
the element of surprise we can you know
we can stage to get ready to attack and
then I can start with I'd like to do a
scan of the battle area so that I can
determine what type of weapons these
guys are holding camp fire you see the
mouth of a cave leading up so it's low
ground where the fire is then it's about
a 30-foot incline into the mouth of a
cave right here you have about a 10 to
20 foot cliff face right here that goes
around the edge mm-hmm and then you just
have open plains everywhere else you
just can't see what's up top of here and
you can't see what's in the cave because
obviously it's above your eye line well
the goblins armed the goblins are armed
with spears yes and wonder what their
distance for throwing a spirit is you
can make an assumption that they might
be able to throw it as far as you can
I'm thinking like 30 feet would be a
good chunk for a spear but I could be
wrong so we have a couple options here
fellas we can bum-rush them and try and
intimidate them and force them into the
cave but we don't know the black things
a cave their cave and there could be
more Baba's guys
yeah gentlemen snip I offer a strategy
sure I've I've been tinkling that I can
cast within 90 feet so I'd only have to
move 10 feet forward to cast it and then
we can track them while you guys kind of
head towards the two trees and blocking
the view and maybe we can use that
entanglement to prevent them from moving
closer and using their own Spears how
far we move per turn five feet right
okay you see and I'll start off ten feet
can I suggest something for them
why don't you yeah slowly creep up on
them because if I can land here like I
said I can use my javelin and if
somebody can't come here they can use
another yes like Melody's right there
and then I'm with my rack and then I can
hide yeah but it's a movement can I hide
jump in and attack I'm getting right on
my p.w I'm more barrier you could if you
want to if you want to look cool if you
want to look cool you can jump in
so I'm saying I'm saying for me to get
from here to here [ __ ] to do that out
here sorry for me to get from here to
here is about two to three to two terms
like a little over to be fair you guys
are not in combat yet so there's no
restrictions I'm always just be careful
with how quickly you move like prints if
I just like okay I'm going here and I'm
not gonna give you guys much like leeway
on what happens like some could have
caught you movement through there also
like for starters I would say
I would say that you guys would roll
sneak like you roll a stealth pack okay
you could even roll one individually or
you could have one rule for the problem
themselves right now
okay herbs okay I'll be good
zennith thank you for the follow so I'm
gonna let me do me let me give me hold
me I got a tingle then take the butter
yeah fine feet forward me open because
I'll be with you aren't you gonna pick
this one can I stealthily move to this
tree right here and hide behind it which
is on this tree this tree this tree this
tree I did not let general Craig's
movement then we'll all move all your
path for me yeah well I can't draw but
the idea be I go from here to here so
that's two turns like this yes yes go to
the first go to this tree first go to
the first tree you're gonna go - I do
cuz I've been patient you try to do peak
over you what's your right now
is that cool because basically I'm gonna
go here I'm gonna go here with Craig and
then these two guys are gonna just like
somehow pop up here and go like a gang
Shawn's staying still some LD you can go
wherever you okay I'm going to move
right here
well the hook is right here clean it
just on the on the end no they're gonna
see your dog look at that look at that
point of view dude they're not very
attention were quite well goblins are no
like individuals Pecos right now I'm
within striking distance of entanglement
was there talk of entanglement so that's
gonna wrap them up in like twines and
stuff and hold them there so my
entanglement as an ID you can you can
click it just click it and it will go
into the chat for everyone to see it
okay how do you do that arrow thing like
with the line not yet no not yet this be
a creature of the area when you cast the
spell must succeed on strength saving
throw or your mother continual plants
until the spell ends a creature
restrained by the plants can use it such
action to make a strength check against
you as well ok so it's a gamble though
right it sounds like a so
so just say no Mellie has a spell save
of Ted so the if she if he used entangle
goblins would have to pass at end they'd
have to roll above a 10 or meet attend
to free themselves just so you guys know
are we gonna have to run through that
entanglement to get close enough to them
to hit them we don't want to eat
hinderer yes so it's so it's it's 20
feet so it'd be like this this whole
area is kind of going to be entangled
okay that makes sense
30 okay we're gonna be a battle starts
right so we're gonna have to trek
traverse all this area using yes yeah
what no okay but it's my turn right
everybody move okay it's my turn then
right thank you yes right here and then
pop up here so I'm going here and then
here you know I don't know how to do
that thing where you're doing like
double clicks but you right-click so so
if you're dragging with left click you
hit right click yeah it's only one turn
right so I moved right here so that I
have shitty stuff if I moved a Craig
yeah restriction so you can do whatever
you want but I just need the boys okay
while you're doing that when you're
about halfway
goblin that's taking that's that's one
watch above on the cliff will spawn you
halfway across and will initiate by you
stepping on the branch yelling out a
warning and these three not really
knowing where there's no real they call
out but they're just Delaware that
someone's so coming in it it's my
character trait you hear once that
goblin yells that out you hear that's
like a loud a loud roar oh dang let's go
Oh No well what do you boys think you
have a goblin we're gonna do right now
is we're going to roll for initiative on
your character sheet on your character
there should be a bun that says int or
initiative investigation inside its raid
next to it's right next to armor class
there should be a word - Wow damn I
didn't mind oh good let's go ready never
uh covens rolled it goblins roll the
twenty as well what happened is at I
will go to crash
but Craig will go then the goblins will
take their turn and then the rest of the
group okay so I will throw my javelin
now I'm trying to be
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
in the rack
[Music]
the word
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's the goblins turn yep it is now
goblins turn so what we have here is
we'll get two movements first either way
I will come out of the cave you see two
extra goblins I'm ready for this these
two goblins that are up on top will make
without falling it looks like what this
one made it down fine
this one's tripped and fell in his pro
it's gonna be stuck there for the turn
[Music]
[Music]
which says you're a CEO of 13 so
anything that's 13 or lower lower misses
its 14 or higher I rolled the cell I'm
dead at 17 so he well what about my own
armored defense but act equals 10 plus
your dexterity modifier or your armor
class egos yeah so 10 plus 3 will be 13
[Music]
or HP for him
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know what I'm gonna pull up on them
when they pull over is correct I'm gonna
test rolling is the common roses of
Marty
[Music]
we'll attack you with a scimitar Craig
the sanatorium got [ __ ] goblin is a
scimitar so it's a 10
what is Craig so that the spear just
clangs off it's only chainmail but still
kind of just grazes you and you kind of
step to the side this goblin will rush
forward or it's the opposite side of the
tree
[Music]
the order that you want that make sense
because you guys are all going and you
guys are on the same area so can i
attack now I will cast entanglement
really like team are we retreating are
we gonna fight no sense right now what
you just said you walking into the
sewers
don't worry we'll be closer present
danger these key right here
[Music]
okay all right it's on now they can
spell wise and I got a deal okay I'm
gonna kill this if I can I kill the guy
that's attacking credit now if I don't
these other cities
[Music]
I mean if you want take of those
batteries that owners are just fine yeah
that's still but you still have these up
here yeah but this guy's prone this
guy's prone he's [ __ ] up he tripped
he's these two piece we are in our
challenge right
okay what's the thing with that out so I
could run away right like this is 30
feet or to the bag right here this is
Craig I invested and then I'm gonna move
a move I'm gonna move a little closer
say no as smell is an action bonus
action then this is Craig nobody misses
me so let me just get this this melody
so forth and I will be right
[Music]
Yankel okay roll that [ __ ] let's go sign
with your [ __ ] mother
drop the clicking okay I don't see
there's like there's like a square a
[Music]
strength safe to try to break free but
the brain down there in ten can i okay
so I'm gonna Yolo and I'm gonna kill
this guy right here I'm gonna tack okay
I'm gonna yellow okay so I'm gonna Yolo
and move in attack Craig's character I'm
going to use
can I move there Shawn character Goblin
can I jump over okay that's what I'm
doing doesn't do athletic check yeah so
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
know you're gonna get some better pika I
have pre athletic it's gonna be a DC
[Music]
okay well I'm gonna doing right now
athletic right well sure well as you
attempt to jump over Craig you you're
like halfway over and you think you're
already over you know I mean so you're
already prepping for the landing but
your heel comes smacking into the back
of Craig's head what happens is you land
flat up right and Craig is force prone
his face planted but you didn't attack
you are on the other side
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I want to roll my dice with the highest
numbers like I get the most hits out of
it right like my magic missile I only
roll 1/4 plus 1/4 damage that's not
going to be very much thank you do use
what you want to use but it does have a
bunch of perks like a split between or
have them all hit the same one so I
could do 20 damage all for him how about
you just just click the word fireball
the red no it would pop up in chat bro
I need you to roll a d20
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on war damage so the fireball connects
does it make it from the Goblin stick is
out and Millie's character gets aroused
[Music]
I'm sorry you're good you could still
hear when you're prone up so I want to
stand
[Music]
[Music]
What's in just summer photos okay here
hold on real quick
fun fact if you put on your character
right now if you click on yes there's a
little settings wheel I have no I'm
sorry I'm sorry
did you see the green circle that has
your HP well mine's up for ya so it says
for Sophie got you can click on it and
then you can type in the new number and
hit enter okay so when you when you heal
or take damage you responsible for now
[Music]
we want to go
what's the move do we want to go over
here we want to go over here
I was certainly back up to punish you
far for us we only have 15 feet crack so
stay back okay it is now the dog let's
turn then the goblins will they need to
be a need to be 210 so I'm gonna do
three starting with the front one and
backwards so boy that's a fail pass two
of them gone on this one is still this
one right here is entangled in these two
survive this this beer goblin will
actually earn bit take us attention on
to the druid casting spells will move up
and throw spirit thanks Melanie in the
face
there are 13 don't die on us melody what
do I see my AC will go to your armor
class and it will hit you for three
damage this goblin will stand up this
government is no longer covered throne
but he can only move 15 feet I don't see
their doors you don't see their equate
you don't see any of their helpers at
all I'm sorry
you should be able to see the red bar
let me see this right here okay
[Music]
my turn now can I rescue Craig adaiah
but once again you hear a loud coming
from the cave but at the same time after
the board what is all the commotion at
health care oh we got a dip your
tweeting exists now that's a [ __ ]
it's a giant it's a giant can't dip
because hold on no yeah
[Music]
yeah poser you concentration is now the
rest of the party an attack and I'm not
jumping yeah you know what nope yeah I
know
so you're like this you guys have
advantage of your flanking if you're
flanking you'll have advantage on your
that's what I'm doing go ahead have to
always go to my bio and make like great
acts right
[Music]
you cut up for a second what is it like
slice and once again no no I just cut
his dick off
no no no I sliced the bottom half of his
bottom I slice the bottom half of his
body and he's crawling on the ground and
then I see
I dunno what adjacent is now your turn
all right the moment
so my stubborn action so fight casts a
spell I cannot move correct yourself
movement movement and actions are not
the same all right all right I need to
be within 10 feet be poison spray so I
want to move towards I need to move okay
you can't give up your action to sprint
which is doubling your movement so you
can say I'm going to sprint this turn in
front 60 feet you just won't get in
action because you're actually running I
sure as hell can't Craig okay
what 60 what are you [ __ ] leave so
why don't you just try talking okay all
right
let's do that I'm gonna move 20 I'm
gonna move as close as I can why do you
have to move that's a good one that's a
good one doing does my feet okay so I
would do that I would do that and try to
maybe I'm gonna help works but if I
don't kill him
[Music]
why'd you get closer Bellamy's dead give
it to me the screen the creature must
succeeded Constitution save me Thor take
112 poison okay so he will have to make
[Music]
Constitution save what this only needs
to be yours
[Music]
we'll roll it
works out maybe we'll take one be 12:12
sandwich damaged this God takes kill it
[Music]
first seems fine then you just start
seeing his face sort of bubble and just
slowly blood falling from his nose and
he just collapses oh maladies about
again dude melodies about to die
do - ah no you have to go for this guy -
[Music]
you don't really have an angle there's
one melodies in between others a rush
from the tree and behind me
[Music]
hey what are you going to do a frigid
beam of blue-white light shrieks it
takes the three came for the you know
you hit with that frost that kind of
shakes it off you know it's just like
I've been here before I know what this
is you just rolled like [ __ ]
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna target this boffo
[Music]
backflips or whatever the [ __ ]
[Music]
these three goblins I want to finally
push forward because they are now not
restrained and get to you this goblin
will iron right here
[Music]
[Music]
Baggett's all right so what we'll do
we'll go through a couple different
things we will have first the spear will
be tactic Craig if Scotland ran from you
Craig will be exactly with the spear - I
don't think that hits will throw his
sphere at melody just just witnesses one
of his dear brother blood brothers now I
know missed a poison and so he furiously
hugs br7 who actually doesn't miss you
guys see lumbering out of the cave is a
table that's a little bit bigger a
little bit more well armored than any of
the comments that you're fighting right
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright alright I [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
with that
so I'm over here yeah I'm sure you'll be
fine yeah this isn't gonna be a problem
I ain't scared dude
and cohort you have three dudes that'll
be surrounding you though so you might
even want you to shut up
I got it okay he's gonna be fine so I'm
gonna go to my pika thing right now and
then how do I do the rage thing Alex
I do just tell me that you're raging
click the word rage okay Rick is that an
action or do I not on the not a lot
attack can i rage in an attack or no
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna read I'm gonna rage
[Music]
you see the chat bubble to the right of
it you see the little
little shadow
you speaka explodes in a ball of rage
all damage besides psychic
he also deal to more damage in all
attacks you have two charges of rage and
rage ends if you go one round without
taking or doing damage all right you are
now raging you are now okay question
slap shooting wait I have I know I have
two different weapons or I still have a
great axe and an axe when I attack with
the hanoks it has like a different role
it says 1 d6 + 2 the great axe will do
more damage than hand axe it's just
something that you're holding in case
you lose another weapon it's just great
axe baby
I got a 16 boom is dead I'm gonna slice
his head open or slices head off grab
his head and then show the other goblins
and the one with the shield that do that
and then and I roar can't do that
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'll try to check out that guy to my
right this guy this dude's gonna finish
did I try to because I didn't kill that
dude
I think the wonder one yeah yeah yeah
these two are troops together why don't
I get off this wagon okay thanks Dylan
of a suggestion it has four remaining
health wait how much huh
does it look like he has more how come
it says for melody there's no way you
[ __ ] this up unless you bet okay all
right
here
[Music]
it would be phenomenal [ __ ] looks like
it's like right here
I will get his goblin to do a
constitution throw to see if he takes
damage or not
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then Craig will you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's for the meter beat so you win it's
tie goes to the defender I'm gonna get
[ __ ] guys
[Music]
my store rage it's uh three of them it's
all three of you guys yeah you still can
I won't be one the boss kill the to be
[Music]
craig you can heal me though right how
about this how about this i don't go
first how about Shawn attacks right now
attack the big goblin and then melody
moves out of the way first no cuz he
could get all steamed you know but
melody melodies kind of moves yeah he's
gonna bail until it is gonna move either
right here or some [ __ ] so then you can
attack pickup well let me move first
you can't you do can't you do an
entanglement I get a bonus and then you
cast entanglement
kill me he'll attack this guy and then
I'll kill you got any cool spiel I
poison sprinkle me poison spray that
[ __ ] okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're on top of us I wanted to go right
here so that the twenty feet it suggests
or at least Ivar and just misses my Tina
that's not how it works
[Music]
but you don't have to you could
[Music]
Hey save yourself Pecos 11 feet well
this is 11 feet he's one point out early
yes so it's only gonna make my big boss
feet
I don't know
oh okay everything eats a walk okay
yeah go for it he's not okay I know he's
gonna mic my boys gonna make your
concept big my big boy got me good
policy no he is he's a monster okay he's
gonna kill it
no it's gonna be a big role oh okay so
he's gonna take no son let's go son come
on Oh welcome whoa whoa whoa whoa you
don't want a 12550 my damage put this
out slow down dude he could sha Shan can
you just throw a fire there at the guy
just throw a fireball face just hit the
fireball bye cuz I'm gonna move you know
okay you want me to attack these guys
I'm attacking the boss cuz I'm gonna die
dude like straight up unless you Maya
5 HP about 5 HP ok Sean what if I move
forward goes wrong what if what if I
move forward and then you can attack
this guy so then I don't get attacked
from behind
I know magic missle this [ __ ] you 3 3 4
sated 12 we do for several of you 10
damage this guy hasn't managed forgive
you it's not meant for you to ha
oh [ __ ] him let's go go it's my turn my
turn no okay I ready
well let's see if I kill this guy I
think I might be able to one shot in the
leader Falls no we gonna [ __ ] them all
up that's the baby alright so Alec stop
the move okay get back from where I'm at
oh we will 11 son pika pika
how do you kill pika rushes forward and
leaps into the air and slices him in
half
[Music]
but I couldn't gonna have okay I run and
then I just slash it in half okay and I
dress myself a goblin blood
[Music]
let's go okay kill the guy okay so guys
here's my question
duo do I wanna do I want to kill the guy
next to Pete that hear me out the guy
yeah
or do I want to heal Peka Peka problem
whatever I do
well I'm just letting you know if you
[ __ ] up they could ignore you I would
because exactly yeah yeah respected on
craigers okay
yeah well this is literally in half and
this guy's just good staff is the last
remaining member do a con save a
disadvantage
goblins are kind of selfish he's gonna
run he's gonna turn away okay is this
where we try and capture him from the
farmer the Goblin so you're just saying
so you're gonna creep up the hill into
the cave is what you're saying like I'm
gonna go yeah I'm gonna go like creep up
to about here right yep right here and
then I'm gonna just see what the [ __ ] is
in there by using rolling investigate
don't all right so like you can see the
lip of the cat the cat or the cave yes
so you see like the roof of the entrance
but it's still like like five more feet
once you're there
yeah although you see the know Craig I
have a date the cows
wait there's cows let the cows Oh cow
game so that's kind of what you you have
and any creature within 20 which bothers
yeah hey hey you see that Brown [ __ ]
it's treasure chest no in this area I
can castrate for you right here general
Craig and within 20 feet will be able to
do it do I do it do it I know some more
combats can happen and you guys didn't
hear me
yeah combat starts and I can heal you
pika yep cuz you know he's combat so I'm
gonna move to the right here what's the
25 are you going in first you got Lily
HP's son okay well I need to be with it
because let me see how far very far no
stay there you're there now you [ __ ]
up melody you're there now you move
there right here alright I'll be there
as you were walking through you hit a
trip wire that was right here going
across the floor you need to give me a
DCA for us to need a dc-15a you're gonna
die [ __ ] up right now where's the next
dexterity saving throw it's your attack
today under saving throws
okay as your your right here as you snip
the wire with your foot looks the left
and you see a very jerry-rigged wooden
log attached to a rope he released
towards you and you try your best to
dodge but really or you thought it was
coming slower than you did so it just
kind of hits you square in the chest and
you're gonna take on D 12 of damage no
investigators weren't wrap up what are
you guys [ __ ] doing know that we know
that could be more traps yeah I trick I
tripped it I tripped the wire and I was
within here so you can't give him a bet
you can give me a medicine check tender
higher so you you tried to get out you
try to get smelling salts out to kind of
bring them back but you accidentally you
actually put flour up there you thought
flour was the same thing
before you get there I need melody -
unfortunately melody this is kind of
fortunate for you but it probably not
bad you're gonna need to do you see
where it says death saving through see
where's this debt that you do revive
yourself the only thing is just don't
roll on natural one because if you're on
natural one
but that's when you fail rulefive you
failed but you're fine down the other
two can comment relative was if you fail
three deaths Apes
if you roll below a ten three times then
you die okay
Melody's dead so I see melody isn't deep
peril but behind them I do see that
there's a chest so as I make my way over
to melody I stop at the big head honcho
and I would like to search his body for
any interesting facts like a key maybe
yeah go for it give me an investigation
check best to keep this guy's body well
cool so you take about 30 seconds to a
minute and you find a little sack full
of coins you find like a really shitty
sword and kind of like a Benton buckles
shield and then you also find like a
ring of keys like there's no real reason
to them
like some of them might open something
but you really don't
it just looks like a comical jailer key
ring you know I mean there's a hundred
keys on the money in the keys and
discard the rest by nature's grace
general Craig oh you four sounds good
right now I'm investigating I'm
investigating near the chest area and
cutting of the cows okay okay just kind
of you know near the chest so you
noticed that
very absent apps see you see an old
wooden chest two of them right over here
on these tables it's just those are
those tables oh this is the chest with
with an assortment of like either
handmade or just kind of like backyard
built weapons that you think that
goblins were experimenting building some
you see three cows which you can only
pursue more the ones you're looking for
and then that's about all you can see
right now I still think I should cast a
fairy fire from what works well then
[ __ ] do it when it's my turn the
question is there's this area here
that's still dark yep and there's this
area here if that's still dark so what
goblins show up right feel like I feel
like here's where we should see what
smelling you throw your fire fight [ __ ]
and then Sean get in the [ __ ] cave
and open the chest okay you want me to
fairy fire in this area right here right
here sound let's go right here come on
yeah alright alright let me catch the
ferry fire all right so you casted it
cube within ranges range a creature in
that area was a texture DC configuration
ok what I gain from this is that if so
it's like if you were the casted in this
room like the cows and all that would be
outlined in color yeah yeah any creative
creatures if there's any creature like a
goblin this is I don't know you see
through walls
it's like Cassie bumpy you can see
through the wall see an outline creature
if it's there
what a waste melody you should have
moved forward and then thrown it you
should have been like right here you can
see through this wall and see what's it
been out no it's fine it's fine
listen to me hear me out he's got the
key to the bat thing maybe and we got
the cows we just need to get the cows or
whatever is in here and I guarantee you
once we get the cow something's gonna
come from right there that's dark bro
then we good we can escape what the cows
can that's how it works cuz gotta find
six cows we can only see three of them
oh we need six remember can we just give
him three and again half back no heal me
and let's go I'll [ __ ] up anything that
comes at us ya know people like that bro
to see if I can figure out which of
these keys yes just indubitably we're an
insight smart you are
I like you like someone no we did that
we could use that one because I haven't
gotten any dumber
you're probably like you don't know
realistically I mean you do have to be a
master to see a key and know what kind
of market fits into now these are all
generally same sized there's not exactly
a ton of differences I will probably
take you about half an hour to go
through all the keys on that chest okay
but you got a ten so he didn't do it
ome I'm giving him a time frame that it
would take for him to find the right key
if there is one for that walk I'm saying
it would take a helper for him to try
every key
it's 1225 I'm gonna stay here and keep
going through keys okay Sean is going to
be working on that chest during this
time all right someone's gonna hear me
so I come before oh yes I heal Arthur
five points right what was my will so
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do that I can
click my character PKU so PKU you're
sure you're gonna go you're going don't
[ __ ] I just wanna make sure I know I'm
not a [ __ ] check yeah but remember this
trip lawyers there's trip I don't care
about I don't care about when you're
walk I don't care about the line I care
about where your character is didn't you
do a insight or investigation throw to
see if you can investigation so fun fact
I tricked Alex so I'm actually gonna be
going to the bench to collect some loot
or tables a low jump pathway
what happens here do I search or
something like a loon or what's the I
mean yeah just if you want just looking
at the table
it looks so I'm just gonna be flat out
with you there's no weapon on this bench
that's better than the to integrate
actually you carry around with you
that's fine
this looks like this looks like what
people use like this is what goblins did
in their spare time trying to make
weapons for themselves when they knew
their other [ __ ] weapons would break
okay all right we got to speed this up
can I go back to his body over here I
want to go back to the [ __ ] let's go
here too bad I'm going to this guy right
here you can just look over the body
he's got a real [ __ ] spear but this
guy's at low level grunts and he doesn't
have much value so what you're gonna
tell me is everybody except the big guy
at like in the regular game is the only
guy that's not taking I mean he didn't
really have much on him did he he had
keys and gold or coins or something a
little bigger is this one that goblin
gets courage and he comes back on the
attacks Krakus all right so what you're
telling me is okay so tell me so Shonda
shut open the chest yeah okay so no wait
three months yes half an hour yes about
a half an hour you're right you're right
to think about it but we should really
take time to heal recuperate
Alex which is my max HP okay can someone
investigate here yo okay hello team
forward fire within my amateur space
makes no sense literally just
investigate here right here right here
bro investigate this there's a dram and
confer with my with my fellows but trap
right here or investigate right here
no you have to you're looking you're
looking and you don't see any tripwire
all right move for don't be [ __ ] I
don't see any supplier all right I'm
gonna move right here and I would like
to cast fairy fire there's treasure
chests so Sean's gonna need to take a
half hour on each of these damn chests I
noticed one of the keys on the keyring I
have a very good intuition on and I like
to throw a luck to see if it would
possibly open with that key the key that
you have in there a little bit and the
chest opens because it wasn't locked in
the first place stuck the keys in we
don't just but you might not need the
keys so I go in here and I try to open
this chest wait cuz you didn't click
your nose okay so wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute so Sean's just
opening my chest open so what's in the
chests in Sean's chest Sean has
there is a dusty tome you don't really
know what that is you have multiple
Scrolls which may or may not be worth
anything you have no idea
and then there is three or no there's
three packs of three throwing daggers
okay do I recognize the language fifty
tomes and Scrolls are written in
obviously you open the tome and you open
the scrolls yeah the is some sort of
Orcas language the scrolls you scrolls
are same language but it's harder that
really defer what it is you probably
need to have more experienced person
read through and kind of know what they
are whether they're messages or a scroll
of spell you don't know I take all items
all items okay so here's the thing now
so when you're taking items on your
character sheet the bottom it says
equipment you need to add you have to
hit the plus and add things that you're
taking okay Dylan I mean you see Shawn
at the bottom where it shows me below
your weapon see ad book Scrolls stuff
like that okay so pika because Peter got
the most kills rushes past melody and
opens the chest right opened his
craigory Craig over to his chest so
Craig goes to and then I go after I'm
gonna go Mellie didn't open a chest I
got the most kills so I rush over and I
push them over to the side can I can I
do that Oh
you have you open you open the chest you
have there's a very rusty so uh steel
short sword and then there's two
separate bags I'm you open one and it
looks like have like Lo and jewelry like
not like mark not like a ton of large
diamonds or anything like that it's more
like towards me towards gem quick
low-class gems and then the other bag
thirteen gold pieces and eighteen copper
in it oh okay can I do my thing now so
you're gonna add so when you take that
you're gonna add 13 gold and ancient
copper to your sheet crazy you know
where that that it's downwards as
equipment equipment there's gonna be
like so the gold is the the one that you
have one end and Silver's like above
those so I get 19 because there's 18
there you said bingo
there was 18 copper and 13 gold Oh 18
copper okay so I had 94-96 copper 18
plus 18 would be 14 wait yeah 14 and
then in the new 14 gold the second one
from the top and what's that one below
silver I don't worry about that we don't
use that currency it's like that's
platinum okay you know that gold is
worth more than platinum okay now just a
little note for anyone okay the rate of
the future
I'm just telling you what it is right
now real-life ability you're right bro
I'm also su seer all right Sir Arthur
yeah some pika let Arthur go I am
capable no you did not
Thanks thanks for investing in the room
which Arthur failed to do
go ahead aren't there push for Mellie a
way you get to your chest why come up
most stuff okay can I just forcibly can
I am forcibly open it yeah don't ya
don't where is it weird what's when I
click third from the bottom
Dorian s in the lock at first but after
about five seconds of trying you get
really annoyed and just kind of [ __ ]
in there roughing around in you the lock
is so rusty it just kind of snaps and
the case you feel the case kind of lifts
up so when you get please be nothing
please be nothing there's a small vial a
very small and on it there's like a it's
kind of like almost like a cartoon
there's a
little piece of parchment kind of
hatched to it and all it is like do you
know like a person like a stick figure
in the bathroom stall like how it what a
mail stick figure count looks like it's
like the top half of that is that and
then his bottom half is kind of fizzling
away like it looks like it's
disintegrating a point it's like a point
you're telling turning in the turning in
the mist so it's like half of them is
full and then the bottom half of them
stirring in the mist yeah ooh named that
for battle and then you also find like
there's some random clothing in there
that you do not care about and then let
me see what else is there and then I'll
take that how do I do that so you're
taking the potion and you're taking 35
someone my character sheet you'd go down
to the bottom where says equipment and
you'd add one potion and then you'd add
thirty five silver items just said you
hit the plus sign and then you'd add
potion you type potion in my previous a
so verse the triangle silver is that
from 30 because I feel generous I give
10 of it to melody 25 okay okay we out
of this [ __ ] what do I add to my show
so now we got to get that cows right and
take them back to that cow attacks
Craig's hand yes life I've catch I've
kept the nature's
or a fairy fire and all these dudes so
we have advantage on any move we perform
on them sure they're all know the
[ __ ] thing but if you look around
hanging up on some spikes on the wall
you see some like shitty net and then
there's a couple couple loops of pretty
old rope but there is some rope around
alright so we grab the rope and we tie
up the horses together and I do not
leave I still have one action I'd like
to perform okay I think we should do
this is - should it be up front
- should be in the back to herd the cows
okay mean that means that'll be cool you
can read ad that's your way okay
so Sean what would you like to do before
we leave the melody are in the back
getting the cows together Sean looks
over notices large piles of cow manure
as his days as a rough and humbled son
of a silk trader enjoying every populace
in life he has plenty of experience with
some mushrooms the girl on top of cow
patties he looks over at melody and asks
him if you think it'd be a good idea
that they enjoy some of these magical
mushrooms to further enhance the trip
home I'll take a copper key
manure is too recent but now we're just
eating [ __ ] you are gonna do a 2x2 or
what don't like Craig and Craig Ferguson
Arthur up front and then Sean and
highway zoic in back so we can be or
should we be in alignment so Craig guess
we'll take a close-up here I'll be right
here Craig move forward all right and so
you guys this is your plan to move this
is your plan to move back to the this is
your formation on your way back to the
[ __ ] character yes I would like Craig
who is leading to roll just a d20 it's a
regular d20 make a break over here all
our hard work although just a 1 not the
two and just one day 27 okay yeah you
guys start your journey wait what if we
leave five cows here take one back and
tell the farmer where to find the rest
of the other five no what the [ __ ]
no you just I don't give me 100 gold
I'll kill him and I'll kill the sheriff
put this [ __ ] down
together and move the cows back I
continue to stand for mushrooms on my
way back through old cow [ __ ] just to be
able to maintain the cows and bring them
back so you get back into the night and
I'm gonna bring you guys over this way
hold on kind of rode the cows back over
I tired you guys are pretty beat up and
you guys come back okay Sean and Sean
that's offers a circus to the puck where
am I gonna imitate him again okay guys
gang you never know seconds or so a very
sleepy old dwarf comes to the door and
recognizes you immediately and is
immediately his eyes light up you know
you see a lot of life come into him it's
like you're back so soon
any good news yes sign cow [ __ ] worth
noon we have found [ __ ] to bring you
back all your cozy cows if you follow me
you didn't quite see them it can lead a
man a little bit more extra pay trying
to keep up with your long legs strides
yep and what does he think do you think
kind sir he almost you know his jaw
drops almost like imagining you guys
just went off to your death and you
would never be seen again and he's just
he overjoyed oh wait now we go back to
the show are you happy are you happy
with the service we provided yes yes
most certainly you're all right this is
where I use my charisma and we get more
money thank you get the money no no this
is where we talk to you so sir can we
please have our payment and will you
talk kindly of us to others in need of
service yes please just give me a second
and he for real
don't fall is to make sure he's not
pulling anything so he comes back out
with just like a hefty leather sack and
he just holds it out like upwards
towards you Shawn sees that this is
everything I swear and he gives you the
bag like outstretched it sure feels like
a hundred gold demand more money like
ten minutes
hey what we hear all about all right
well let's but but how do we know it's
real gold is there a way to seems good
to me
can only roll to see if he can make me
feel better so the answer is so we got
the dog so we want to thank the cut and
farmers speak kindly of us and yeah we
need to go rest rest we should take and
we'll talk about the about the stolen
vials for that alchemist okay but no no
what I say would you hear me out because
it's already almost 10:00
I said go rest and we call it a day
leave that we've succeeded with our
first wing task 2 hours gamemaster
what say you yes so we'll bring you all
over to the tavern and then we could
choose
[Music]